vom berner oberland in den spanischen
süden miriam thomann und ostsee erfüllen
sich den traum vom leben auf einer
pferde finca
auf einer großen farm im westen kanadas
will familie ruckstuhl endlich ihr glück
finden
mit vier tigern wagt remo müller das
abenteuer erwandert zu seiner freundin
alexandra pitz nach deutschland aus sie
bauen einen tierpark
[Musik]
in saratow im süden spaniens waren die
letzten tage nicht einfach für usb
knapp darüber
[Musik]
als sein geschäftsfreund robert in den
ferien war ist unerwartet eines seiner
lieblings pferde gestorben
nach dem ausritt nehmen sich die beiden
freunde der zeit um auf das ereignis
zurück zu blicken
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
hatte uns den wallach leon eines morgens
tot auf der weide aufgefunden
bis die hühner auf dem hof der familie
ruckstuhl erfüllten die erwartungen
[Musik]
und der vater trieb als waschechter
cowboy eine herde rinder auf einer weide
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im deutschen welle hatten renault und
alexandra auch am tag der tierpark
eröffnung wetterpech unglaublich skis
markt schießt doch den festakt ließ sich
das paar nicht vermiesen jetzt
[Musik]
der plötzliche tod eines ihrer
reitpferde hat mosley mitgenommen
konzern aber nicht mehr für das turnier
das ich für mich reden so waren
erfreuliche nachricht
natürlich das bezahl brikett und er das
pendant christian veh zwei tage die
fähre und jetzt steht das pferd und
frauen
emotionale meistens auseinander dein
größter zu schreiben eine woche lang vor
deiner wenige fehler der votava teri
polo stimmung ist für mich gilt das von
einem pferdehof dazu dass angeboten wird
und immer willkommen
xiao bestanden alle haushalte
funktioniert
[Musik]
robert freundin barbara bataillons tod
besonders geschmerzt doch auch sie weiß
dass weder uns noch miriam eine schuld
trifft sie lenkt sich mit alltäglichen
arbeiten ab und ist froh dass miriam da
ist
zur küche
für die kann das wird und dann abhilfe
und und das gute ist augen wir ergänzen
uns ganz gut finde ich so in dem was wir
kochen wie kochen nicht alles gleich das
ist schön mimi ist einfach mehr so die
französische küche sehr feines saucen
und so ich bin ich lieb' tapas machen
und salate und
nein das ist für das klappt wirklich
super
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zwei stunden südlich von enten fast
schon an der grenze zu den usa bricht
markus ruckstuhl erbsen
die arbeitstage sind lang oft bleibt der
vater über mehrere tage von der familie
fern
[Musik]
das fahren mit riesigen landmaschinen
aber das war schon sein bubentraum
fahrtgeschwindigkeit
pflanzen schnitt alles wird über einen
bordcomputer gesteuert die technik ist
das eine die erfahrung dass andere
[Musik]
waging
marvin vater v60 maschine kenntnisse
und erfahrungen aber fehlerfrei farbig
update der laufzeiten
ein scheißtag oder ausgestopften steinen
internet
aber vorstellen
[Musik]
immer wieder checkt markus die scharfen
messer der erntemaschine
da die erbsen tief gemäht werden müssen
geht schnell eines kaputt
markus chef don hat das 3200 hektar
große ackerland von den ureinwohnern
kanadas gepachtet
sechs männer stehen im einsatz jeder von
ihnen hat eine halbe million franken
gekostet
[Musik]
meine maschinen
einen schönen ort gibt es nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch zu hause in enten lebt alexandra
ruckstuhl ihren traum
ein eigener garten mit eigenem gemüse
das war einer der gründe weshalb die
familie ausgewandert ist
in ihrem kleinen reich erntet alexandra
ruckstuhl noch alles von hand
zehn jahre
später
herrschte familie
[Musik]
seit sechs wochen ist der tierpark in
deutschen bell eröffnet bei schönem
wetter läuft der park prächtig
[Musik]
neben den vier sibirischen tigern haben
70 weitere tiere ein neues zuhause
gefunden
es ist ein tierpark der den besuchern
vor allem den kindern die natur wieder
näher bringen will
[Musik]
oder möchte ich sie erst mal hier recht
herzlich auf unserer damenwelt visa
begrüßen ich freue mich dass sie hier so
zahlreich erschienen sind unsere raten
hier die sind aus dem tier an die haben
wir kürzlich übernommen das sind sechs
brüder und alexandra takes kann die
fähigkeiten ihre lieblinge englich einem
großen publikum zeigen
müssen warten ob sie auf die idee kommt
wieder raus zu kommen da ist es schon
aber man sieht sie können sich ganz
platt und schmal machen und sich so
einen ganz kleinen löchern und höhen
verstecken lassen wir unsere gesamten
gruppe danke für
[Applaus]
lebt den täglichen trainings mit seinen
vier tigern history museum oft in der
küche und hinter dem restaurant buffet
anzutreffen
klassisch
modern hell keine schlechte position
hält dem thema spricht das für sie aber
erst nachdem letztes halter damals
geschäfte 50 m vor allem bei jungs geld
sicher vor renault und alexandra haben
viel erreicht nur ausruhen auf dem
erreichten das widerspricht remos natur
und einfallsreichtum
die beiden haben bereits eine neue
geschäftsidee dem afrikanischen milch
kommt dabei eine besondere aufgabe zu
wir werden
den letzten probeflug machen weil wir
morgen die traum unserer gäste
stattfindet und mehr darf die ringe
bringen im tierpark hochzeiten feiern
dies der plan noch sind die beutelchen
steine morgen soll mit mit trauringen
fliegen
[Applaus]
super
das gibt einen riesen stückchen gleich
sie muss den applaus erst genießen und
dann kommt sie wieder wettgemacht
gut gemacht wäre dass wir sogar
noch applaus für dich gemacht aber es
ist interessant dass sie sich auf einem
fremden handschuhe immer mehr zeit lässt
aber das gute ist sie wird die ringe
bringen und dann werden alle menschen
lernen ein bisschen geduldig ein
generalprobe gelungen aber alexander
weiß um die unberechenbarkeit ihres
lieblings
[Musik]
der bauernsohn usb ist einer der immer
viel geleistet hat in der schweiz
arbeitete er jahrelang für eine
schwerreiche unternehmer familie und
führte deren aufträge aus
in trockenen andalusien ist es die natur
der er sich anpassen muss das wasser
fließt nicht einfach so aus dem hahn
täglich muss es vom fluss zur finca hoch
gepumpt werden
eine routinearbeit war und doch genau so
hatte es sich immer gewünscht
hätte ich das richtig zu machen sich
daraus eine gewichtige
dem ohne strom
[Musik]
auf der finca stellt das tagesprogramm
für die gäste zusammen
inzwischen ist auch miriams meinung
gefragt die 43-jährige hatte anfänglich
mühe sich gegenüber robert durchzusetzen
meine right tackle macht das was nützt
es wenn man hätte das quartett den
ganzen
platz
zwei
also ich freue mich auf unsere
gemeinsame zukunft
beim streaming media ag vorm
[Musik]
auch in kanada gibt die natur den
arbeitsplan vor die arbeiter sind in
verzug wegen des regens konnten die
männer erst ab mittag gehen jetzt in der
nacht wollen sie die verlorene zeit
aufholen
[Musik]
markus kam nicht weiter dreschen sein
erntedank ist voll er wartet auf den
wagen der in die erbsen abnimmt
da
mitzumachen
[Applaus]
endlich kann markus seine ernte abladen
doch auch in dieser nacht wird der 31
jährige erst nach mitternacht ins hotel
kommen
daheim ist seine frau alexandra schon
früh auf den beinen sie kocht ihr frisch
geerntetes gemüse ein
damit der wofür die gefilmt so dass mit
dem wieder hier ist das rra benutzer
bliebt will als putzfrau und viel
hier alles immer innerhalb kommunalbank
wieder weg oder dreckig oder was auch
immer und das ist ja bereits gestellt
bekommt haben auch nur filiale geworden
unser quartett
ja locker mal zu oft ja schon
[Gelächter]
alexandra ist endlich angekommen die
letzten jahre waren ein auf und ab die
schlimme krankheit von tochter josephine
das zurückkehren in die schweiz das
neuerliche auswandern nach kanada
wir glauben immer so entspannt sie
wieder letzter
wir sind jetzt erstmal
warten ist
normalität
außer normalität mit schlafen und
wachrhythmus somit meinen rhythmus mit
händen rhythmus ich weiß es die finden
und den bekommt man sagt ja so normal
harmoniert
ist schön
[Gelächter]
es scheint dass das glück den weg in
ruck stuhls alltag gefunden hat
und das wetter bei klm gern in das
damals schön
[Musik]
ob schönes oder schlechtes wetter jeden
abend will die jungunternehmer remo
wissen wie viele eintritte verkauft
worden sind
[Musik]
also ich dich reklamation ich habe nicht
so
können damit leben
[Gelächter]
ich geh dann mal küche gucken guten
appetit
mit rund 20.000 eintritten im jahr ist
das überleben des parks gesichert
spezielle events sollen zusätzliches
geld bringen auftakt macht das morgige
hochzeitsfest darum gibt es heute keinen
feierabend für den gelernten koch remo
ja das ist ja immer gemacht und
unsicherheit die zusätzliche
einnahmequelle wenn man arbeit events
und alles arbeit
als business will man nicht weiß was der
leitspruch ist wenn es um punkte
gerechnet oder so denn so schmid also
muss im wasser
zusätzliche arbeit und dann ein notfall
ok und dann
ja
[Musik]
mach dir
weiterhin spazieren und irgendwie
sind gegen eine angesprungen und der
einzige unterschied platzwunde unter dem
auge
[Musik]
schließe
ich weiß jetzt einmal auf geplatzt da
oben
[Musik]
muss sie zum tierarzt oder
ich glaube schon
doch während der rückfahrt zum tierpark
versucht remo den tierarzt zu erreichen
ja ich bin sehr froh dass ich nach dem
wischen kann er wirklich immer alles
stehen und liegen lässt um ihr zu hilfe
kommt ja ich jetzt nicht tragisch aber
muss wahrscheinlich genäht werden
danke tschüss
doch der vierjährige border collie hat
klickt beim tierarzt zeigt es sich dass
die wunde nicht genäht werden muss
[Musik]
monatelang bewohnten haus und miriam
eines der zimmer inmitten des beste
betriebs
endliche süßes
umziehen wo man es lang lang ruft freute
mit diesem resort
mit dass sie mit mini verließ sie mir
immer alles mit einfacher gewohnt sind
termine
wichtigen themen und nk und jetzt
natürlich ist auf zwei stück viel mehr
platz haben einfach glück
[Applaus]
hoppla hopp
sie ziehen um in ein kleines schale
abseits der gästehäuser
bis vor kurzem hatte der spanische
eigentümer der finca hier gewohnt
die ganze einrichtung hat er den
schweizern überlassen
das war vielleicht wenn ich mal hin
das geht
ja schön und schlank ist wunderbar kraus
viel platz das ist alles für mich die
fachpresse sorry
und das ist alles wieder
headley wenige
hier
das freut mich
sehr schön
viele familien
warum
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ausgerechnet am tag des hochzeits festes
ist seit langem wieder ein schlechtes
wetter
erneut ist ein trupp helfer angereist
der renault an diesem tag unterstützt
wird das nächste komplette mitschnitt
kann der
nach dem salat gibt pochierten lachs
roastbeef hühnchen und rollbraten
[Applaus]
in der tiger arena erwartet die 60
köpfige hochzeitsgesellschaft
den segen für das paar
[Musik]
sie sehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der fahrer findet die richtigen worte
ja so ist das leben sonne und regen
erleben auch und hier sind ja viele
dabei die das schon erlebt haben und
noch erleben
das wird aufregend kleiner
wichtige aufgabe jetzt
was du machst das schon höre auf geht's
[Musik]
ich denke
einmal drauf zeigen darf
immerhin mehr
[Applaus]
das mädchen
[Musik]
die gelungene trauung lässt alexandra
und remo an die eigene gemeinsame
zukunft denken wir können uns erst mal
anschauen wie andere das machen und wir
machen uns
findest du auch geld dann kanns noch mal
pflegen aber nicht vollstreckt aber ich
muss nicht unbedingt die beträge
[Musik]
ganz so
hast du gut gemacht
[Musik]
gemüse
die haben die gemüse
[Musik]
es sind nur ganz ganz dünn
los
mit
[Musik]
es gelingt dem erntedankfest ist auch
markus endlich wieder zuhause
rückstoß mädchen haben neue
spielkameraden vier kätzchen und
die gegen josephine den willen trotz
körperlicher behinderung bäume zu
erklimmen
[Musik]
in der küche hat die mutter ihre eigene
herausforderung
machen wir mal zum ersten mal selber und
köchin große ganze
es sei zu hoffen dass allein mit
dem fleisch hat acht kilo fleisch
[Musik]
ängste wing ein feiertag an dem man mit
dankbarkeit auf das vergangene jahr
zurückblickt
internet bis 10
und das vor allem sozial offen ich das
nicht passiert
ist darum halte
[Musik]
auch alexandra ist voller dankbarkeit
ist selbstverständlich
extrem selbständig können schnell
selbständig
dass das nicht so schnell die
fortschritt machen
zu viert an einem tisch doch an diesen
tisch hätten noch mehr kinder platz
gibt und tom prämiert sind auf top flow
sei es etwas
ruhiger
heimat im herzen wahl probieren und
hoffe dass es einfach gut und vielleicht
sagen auf mit
meinem herrn zwei herzige durch traum
[Musik]
ich fühle mich
gerade punkt
[Musik]
das erste hochzeitsfest im park war ein
großer erfolg
alexandra und remo haben es geschafft
und ihren tierpark um einen weiteren
höhepunkt bereichert aber
ein ausruhen gibt es nicht
wir sind wieder dort zum frühstück als
gut wenn ich das jetzt um spricht das
auch mal grenzen der christ hat doch
bilder gemacht oder
xing
noch vor wenigen wochen stand ja park in
much die tiergehege waren marode und
muss neu gebaut werden viele wo das sein
oder auch goethe seit der ja das ist ja
ihre trauben aber das wird sicher
albtraum ergehen wenn
man wirklich einfach
krampft die ganze tour um 1 irgendwie
herr braucht also zucker wenn es
irgendwie geht auf keinen fall machen
das ist jetzt so wie es ist also für
mich ist der absolute höhepunkt das
regen endlich hier wohnt nicht wieder
wegfährt und seitdem fühlt sich das für
mich auch echt wien zu hause an und ich
würde nichts anders machen ich bin
absolut zufrieden so wie es jetzt ist
und bin erstaunt dass ist genau so
geklappt hat wie wir uns das vorgestellt
haben
und die kann da
und denken uns alle
[Musik]
der umzug der vier sibirischen tiger war
eine der ganz großen herausforderungen
seiner auswanderung
[Musik]
innert kürze haben sich remus lieblinge
an die neue umgebung gewöhnt oder merkt
man schon dass sie halt viel kontakt mit
mir auf und das vor allem folk sie sind
glaubt das vierte gesehen und deshalb
viel größer
[Musik]
laufen im weg und alles mit
achtung
auf dem posten
und sie
entworfen von ihrem meister persönlich
2300 quadratmeter groß ist die neue
heimat der tiger
[Musik]
will sie das studio aber weil sie mit
abstand die größte und dass mir eine
tierpflegerin hundetrainerin das den
aufgestellten das macht einen schon
stolz
kein mensch ist zu klein um seine träume
zu leben
groß aber müssten entschlusskraft und
glaube daran sein
alexandra und remo haben in der neuen
heimat ein fundament geschaffen das
ihnen raum für viele weitere ideen
bietet
[Musik]
das leben in ruckstuhl es neue heimat
ist ein leben voller abwechslung
und josephine die wegen ihrer krankheit
große probleme mit den gelenken und dem
knochenbau hat hat hier viel mehr
möglichkeiten sich zu bewegen so auch zu
reiten
[Musik]
noch haben die ruckstuhl es kein pony
für die kleine
dafür darf josef in ihren ersten ritt
auf einem der pferde von pharmachef
dollar machen
[Musik]
jack ma
hatte gleich noch aus hat sie der firma
grundy mache
auf der suche nach einem neuen glück in
der weite kanadas mussten die ruckstuhl
es einen umweg machen
[Musik]
ihre erste auswanderung hatten sie jede
abbrechen müssen weil töchterchen
josephine schwer krank gewesen war
[Musik]
vielleicht ist es gerade dieser umweg
denn die ruckstuhl heute ihr neues leben
bewusster und intensiver leben lässt
[Musik]
wenn jemand ans auswandern denkt dann
sind es vielleicht genau diese bilder
die locken schier unendliche weite
abenteuer gemeinsames glück
[Musik]
miriam und os haben ihre sicheren jobs
aufgegeben das mondäne stadt verlassen
um im heißen süden spaniens ein neues
leben zu beginnen
[Musik]
im neuen leben sind sie nicht nur
liebespaar sondern auch arbeitskollegen
geworden und sie haben neue facetten
aneinander entdeckt
ich glaube mit der oft viel besser
kennen
mit klarinette solo ist das mutig was
mir gemacht hat bislang zwei maximum
auch als er die karriereschritt das ist
jegliches restrisiko
wir haben quasi die hufe schlaflose
nacht habe es
wieder
machen
ich habe mich zu sehr mit der oz machen
dann jetzt hinter welle machen nicht
macht
dieser
massivität da
haben wir gar kritik
das buch nicht längst im moment moment
[Musik]
das ist so
noch kommen die kleinen intensiven
momente zwischen den beiden zu kurz doch
die beiden wissen dass sie und nur sie
selbst ihr schicksal in der hand haben
[Musik]